the Joe Rogan experience I mean that
that debate last night did you watch it
no yeah I don't watch them then pushed
Tulsi Gabbard out I stopped watching
unless you guys are out of your [ __ ]
mind she's the most interesting
candidate out there yeah next to Marion
Williams that [ __ ] is crazy I'm crazy
no I say no it's a term of endearment
but isn't she like a crystal healer or
some [ __ ] yeah she was trying to come on
the podcast too she's doing a tour yeah
that is that's a boat with a lot of
holes in it and they're gonna make it
across the harbor it was like talking to
it's like talking to what are your
answer a 20 crazy ants yeah comes over
for the holidays you know and so what do
you don't want I'm a day you a
dreamcatcher anything thank you I think
Bernie Sanders has some interesting
thoughts and talking to him in person in
real life I like him a lot and he's not
like what he comes off in those goddamn
debates because those debates are
ridiculous you get five people in front
of the camera you ask him a question
they have 30 seconds to answer it
everybody else is jumping and yelling
things out they're all trying to get a
soundbite that's all it is it's not it's
not actually a debate I mean remember
you don't debate club I mean yes and
it's not it's not that it's it's exactly
yeah it's exactly what you said it sound
bites a series of sound bites they're
all looking to have a moment yeah you
don't want to screw up so they want to
have a kind of a safe moment right and
they go through I agree with you I like
I like Bernie because he's been
consistent you can go back to the 80s
yeah say in the same [ __ ] they in now
yeah and and I think there is something
to that now I don't I don't buy as his
arguments you know I don't I don't but I
like the guy and I like the fact that
he's consistent and he means what he
says
and so I you know I again I'm I can
separate out liking him from like in his
policy yeah I don't see a problem there
but I don't think they're gonna let
Bernie there was it there was a moment
I'll tell you about last night that won
this debate thing where I think it was
to CNN moderator
she asked Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren had come out the other day and
said that she had a private conversation
with Bernie and during the conversation
yeah Bernie said oh you're a woman's
never gonna win that's my purse
is never gonna win can't win being
president I he was more eloquent than
that but the voice sounded just like it
and and so he's denied it so the
moderator last night during this debate
asked Bernie Sanders let me just be
clear she said are you saying that
you've never said this to Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie said absolutely not
very next words out of the moderate
mouth was she turned or was born said so
senator Warren when Bernie said to you
that he never or no when Bernie said to
you that a woman couldn't be President
how did you feel
Jesus Christ that was it that and so I
think that they're not even trying now
to hide the fact that they want to
marginalize Sanders yeah so why did they
want to marginalize him because I think
they feel I can't there's no way you can
win know what it is yeah I think on a
national level I think the devil is
above Warren can win after line about
being Native American for our whole life
yeah yeah that's a [ __ ] big one to me
[Applause]